welcome back this is the Ben Shapiro
show we're hanging out with you at eight
five five two three six thirty two
twenty eight that is eight five five two
three six 32:28 Aaron in Illinois you're
on the bench beyond struggle for Derek I
event I know you're not one for
conspiracy theories but there's a juicy
one going around about how the
governments around the world are
installing 5g towers that caused the
corona virus symptoms and are a form of
population well what would you have to
say they're that crazy that's crazy yeah
I know there is to say about that other
than that is absolutely bat bleep loony
I've seen no evidence whatsoever that 5g
towers are causing coronavirus symptoms
and even if they did cause coronavirus
symptoms I'm not sure how they would
cause coronavirus deaths and if somebody
had a weapon that powerful don't you
think that they probably would have used
it on people before I mean that sounds
like an amazing weapon honestly like we
should we should deploy that in
anti-terror is owns apparently if all we
have to do is install 5g Tower and we
can knock out like all bad daddy's baby
friends that way it sounds pretty
awesome but that's that's that's pretty
wild that right there hey thanks for the
theory I appreciate it as right in New
York City you're on the bench pinnacle
for Ezra and thanks for taking my call
so I was wondering do you think there's
a way to solve the national debt and if
so how would you go about doing so
unfortunately the only way to actually
solve the national debt is to take on
the institutional structures that so
many people have decided are crucial to
America and that means actually looking
at privatizing Social Security for
younger people allowing them to invest
their own savings rather than
confiscating it from them in a giant
pyramid scheme it means that you would
have to restructure Medicaid and
Medicare all of these programs
constitute about 66 percent of the
federal budget every year and their
mandatory spending meaning that even
when there's a government shutdown those
things not only keep spending but also
they are automatic it's not as though
the budget fights that we have every
year are over the majority of spending
there over a vast minority of spending
the only way to really do this would be
to take a look in a in a very real way
at how Medicare operates maybe have
health savings accounts that are set up
for younger people as opposed to having
the government confiscate wealth from
them and pay them back in terms of
Medicare it's well one of the things
about Medicare that's interesting is of
course a lot of seniors have been
have been taking advantage of Medicare
Advantage which is a supplemental
insurance that they can buy and is more
free market based the same thing is true
of Medicaid the their studies that
demonstrate that Medicaid is actually
not particularly effective even for poor
people that having no insurance is not
necessarily worse than having Medicaid
in many cases because so many doctors
don't actually accept Medicaid all of
these programs need to need to be you
know examined scrutinized and then
restructure to avoid the vast amounts of
debt we are taking on in those programs
that really is the everyone who is
serious about the national debt
understands these programs have to be
restructured alright thank God really
appreciate it as run yeah you have a
great Passover as well Dan and New
Jersey are on the bench pol go for Dan
hey Ben thanks taking a call go for it
sir yep
yes so first of all thanks very much I
have crazy training else but certainly
in my head appreciate that my question
for you is there's a lot of crazy
criticisms going around about the Trump
administration from mainstream media etc
my question is is the whole lack of a
testing regimen would that be something
that we could be fairly criticizing the
Trump administration if so what could
they do in a reasonable way to actually
like really ramp up the regimen regimen
right now yeah I mean Dan there see
here's sort of my view of the Trump
administration response bad up until
mid-march good after right now that's
sort of my take and I think that's true
for a lot of state governments as well I
can recall most being given all sorts of
credit but the state shut down order in
New York didn't happen until mid to late
March the same thing happened in LA
mayor Eric Garcetti as I've mentioned
allowed the LA Marathon to go on full
bore on March 7th March 8th I believe so
you know the sort of revisionist history
where everybody was right on top of this
thing in February it's just not true now
with that said could Trump have done a
lot better in February yeah he could
have taken a leadership role he could
have said instead of downplaying the
thing and sort of giving us the
information we were all operating off of
he could have said listen here are the
risks and by late February he could have
been saying we need you know a lot more
significant ramping up of resources now
I think that the Democrats might've
asked him before that I mean the fact is
that the Democrats it passed with him in
eight point five billion dollar spending
package on like March 6 I believe
they
calling for trillions of dollars in
spending at a time or nationwide
shutdowns at that point so the sort of
consensus the public opinion consensus
did not form late January the notion
that had formed late January the
consensus that we need to shut down all
of society and forcibly put a stop to
the economy and then spread millions of
tests across the country no one was
talking in those terms in late January I
mean I pointed this out on the show a
few days ago that the the simply saying
coronavirus could be a problem does not
absolve you of the facts that you did
not call for serious measures to be
taken in late January indeed anywhere
during February and simply yelling at
Trump about it was not natural solution
so I think a few things can be true
Trump downplayed it Trump kept
pretending that it wasn't a big deal and
was not going to be a big deal and he
was not forthcoming with tons of
information about what exactly was
happening he allowed the CDC to operate
under its own auspices and that was a
mistake the CDC blew the testing regimen
the FDA blew it as far as allowing new
trials and all the rest of this stuff
but once he got serious he got serious
and the media have been fundamentally
unserious by focusing back on stuff that
Trump was saying on February 25th or
February 28th as opposed to the stuff
that he's been saying ever since and
even when they're focusing on the stuff
that he's doing right now it's all stuff
like well he says that he's gonna get
ventilators and there aren't enough
insulators and then you ask all the
governors so have you had like an actual
hard ventilator shortage right now and
like well no not not really and then
he'll say hydroxychloroquine looks like
could be a good thing and the media you
know how dare he how could he say that
then Cuomo says the exact same thing so
again do I think that Trump is over
broad in his language yes - I think that
he says things that are not true about
things that he said before absolutely is
any of that new no what is new is that
Trump in the administration we got
pretty damn serious about this and the
media keep proclaiming that he's
ignoring the scientists in every single
day he's got foul Chi and Burkes out
there speaking directly to the American
public about this stuff so I'm not
seeing the evidence that the Trump
administration is radically botching it
right now I think that there was some
Bochy at the beginning but again I think
that that battery in terms of action was
bipartisan in terms of rhetoric was
worse for Trump than it was for the
Democrats but and and and by the way
worse than it was for Tom cotton who was
on top of this thing very early but with
all that words well yes and I
that's generally been true throughout
his presidency now I do think that you
know he could do more to unify but
that's been true throughout his
presidency as well I mean now would be a
great time for him to you know cut down
on sort of the attacks on the media and
and and he's sort of playing into their
hands when he plays that game you know
he really should be just letting the
people who are better at this speak I
mean like Penn's couch Berks
ouchy Brooks like those would be the
people I would have at the microphone
right now cuz they can answer more
questions then Trump can and I would put
together as as Dana Perino suggested I
think quite rightly an economic advisory
team and have those people answering
questions right explaining what is the
plan to get out of this and what is the
economic blowback going to be like I
think all of that would be useful
Trump is is not his own best advocate
and one of the great failures for
President Trump as he believes he is his
own best advocate because he's such a
counter-puncher well the problem isn't a
time like this well you need to be
putting forward is a calming face and I
do not think the president's face has
ever been described quite as calming
yeah right well thanks a lot that I
really appreciate the breakdown well
thanks for listening really appreciate
it Victoria in Wisconsin go for it
you're on the bench Bureau show hi Ben
thank you it's a great honor to be able
to talk to you there's been a lot of
fear lately as a hearing especially
among conservatives and people of
religious groups particularly Christians
right now and Jews that some of the laws
and policies that are being put in place
for the coronavirus are starting to
reflect that of like the early Nuremberg
Laws that persecuted Jews and led to the
eventual extermination of them where
people are starting to fear that there
might be a police state put in place
that people are going to have their
freedom stripped away and I wanted to
know since you are a Jewish man what
your viewpoint is on that and what you
think about people who are starting to
get fears that there's gonna be right
stripped away that they may not give
back without breaking into a civil war
so number one I always hesitate to make
any sort of Nazi comparison on the basis
of broad policy that equally applies
across the board and isn't specifically
targeting specific religions I mean
these these sort of orders that have
said no mass gatherings and then include
churches and synagogues I don't think
they're specifically directed at
churches and synagogues we've got drones
on the streets of New York telling
people to socially distance so I think
that the draconian measures that are
I'm taking are not religious in nature
and and I think that that is a comfort
I'm gonna start worrying a lot more
about rights being stripped if we are
still doing this on the basis of
uncertain data in a month right if this
continues to be a permanent feature of
American life past the point where the
data can't support it and past the point
where there can even be an argument that
the plans should have been formulated
already then I'm gonna start to get
quite worried and admittedly I think
that that point would come a lot sooner
if I thought that the administration was
deeply invested in maintaining huge
control of the American public like I I
don't think Trump actually wants to do
that one of the problems for Democrats
they keep expressing thoughts like
wouldn't it be great if we just you know
took over a huge swaths of the American
economy that could be the new normal and
that's where I start saying okay are you
guys actually doing this because there's
a pandemic or are you doing this for the
purposes of exacerbating all of your
priors are you are you really trying to
just do all the things you wanted to do
and use this as a cover that that's when
I would start to get suspicious and
that's true across the board so I think
the Trump administration is desperate to
prevent church gatherings know I think
precisely the opposite which is one of
the reasons why I think it's very good
that Trump keeps saying over and over we
want to reopen this thing we want you to
go back to church we want all this to
happen but we have to wait until the
data show it now that is a reassuring
thing to me if we get to the point three
four or five months out where the death
rate on this thing is minuscule and we
have basically come up with some sort of
testing strategy and the people who are
most vulnerable and oldest are still
self quarantine until there's a vaccine
available and still they're telling us
you can't go to church you can't go to
synagogue then I will start to get
worried but up until that point this is
temporary yeah I do believe that it's
temporary and again I tend to be more
suspicious than most of government power
but I also understand that when a
pandemic is happening when data is
imperfect and the fog of war matters but
over time that fog of war has to clear
or the fog of war becomes an excuse to
the growth of government generally all
right well thank you so much than many
lessons to you and your family over
Passover already taking more of your
phone calls Paxton and I while you're on
the bench pro4 Paxton I'm kind of being
it good I guess I'm kind of being a
devil's advocate here I really believe
in mallanna
about everything you say but so you were
talking about how we
need to open up the economy as soon as
possible ah with doing that if there's
like the second wave like they say and
there's a whole book it's a whole lot
worse than what it is now how can we
justify that on humanity I mean I know
you have like more of a pro-choice idea
are a pro a pro-life idea of of you know
life you know every life matters but by
pushing to open up the economy too early
wouldn't that be more of a pro-choice
view well nobody's looking to open up
the economy too early the question that
has not been answered to my satisfaction
or nearly anybody else's is what are we
doing right now that prevents the second
wave I mean I don't know the answer to
that and I've asked a bunch of doctors
what are we doing right now that
prevents the second wave so let's assume
that all we can do to prevent the second
wave is to work with the treatments that
we've got plus increased ICU beds and
ventilators okay great so let's increase
the ICU beds and ventilators so our
health system doesn't get overwhelmed
okay what then like seriously what then
like what's gonna prevent the second
wave so either it's preventable the
second wave or it's not if it is not
preventable then I fail to see why
keeping the economy closed for another
six months is going to help us and if it
is preventable then please spell out the
steps whereby that second wave is
preventable and then we can game out
what exactly that looks like and so far
the only people who have been talking
about that are people like like the the
fellow from the fellow from the FDA and
he's Scott Gottlieb and he's been
talking about you know mass testing and
then contact tracing well I want a
timeline as to when that's actually
gonna be ready and how that is going to
be available because if you want to
develop the contact tracing then you're
gonna have to radically ramp that up and
I haven't seen that happening so the
question becomes which strategy is
better the Sweden strategy of okay we're
gonna lock up all the people or tell
them to lock themselves up all the
people who are vulnerable and all the
people who are older and then we're
gonna let everybody else go out and yeah
there's gonna be more of a death spike
at the beginning but that is gonna wane
quickly and then there is no second wave
or our strategy which is suppress it so
it doesn't overwhelm the healthcare
system which again understandable and
then the second wave is is nearly as big
and so the number of people who end up
dying is very similar to Sweden
except that we ruined our economy and
they didn't write that that is the big
question here so really appreciate the
comment nobody is interested in people
dying here we're looking for choices
where fewer people die and the economy
remains open and functional over time
Paxson really appreciate the call we'll
take more of your calls at eight five
five to thirty six thirty to twenty
eight coming up this is the Ben Shapiro
show